as far as prisons go if we have to be
here
we need
something to reform of
and music
is a direct expression of what we feel
we want to be and to let go of the
things that we don't want anymore
at least correctional institution a
maximum security prison in south
carolina the new york based chamber
orchestra dakota spends a week a year
working with inmates to write music
the inmates included in this program are
chosen by merit
no prior musical experience is necessary
all right i want to learn this in chunks
because you guys are teaching us this
song now which is totally radical and
awesome
before i was never exposed to classical
music or chamber music
or anything that was cultured honestly i
closed myself off to a world of
expression that i never really knew
existed
we have an opportunity in this program
to put away the violence and all these
other mediums of expression
that do nothing but hurt people and we
can channel those feelings and
expressions into music good and now
you're gonna have to lift up
your arm a little bit more
when we're able to practice and actually
get together
and just for that moment just just for
that little bit of time you're able to
take your armor off for once and just
breathe
it's been a big tool to help me change
we have a phrase that we use we have to
act hard you know act tough put on sort
of a facade and we can channel those
feelings and expressions into music
which is the most positive way
to express yourself
you